justement les familles elles sont en
deuil elles ont d'autres préoccupations
a vendu à beaucoup de choses à gérer on
s'est pas posé de question pour nous
faire les toutous tôt supprimés
[Musique]
nous dans nos services ont fait un vrai
effort de recherche et l'ensemble des
données d'une personne suite à son décès
ceux qui ont commencé à accompagner les
familles elle nous donnait un compte
facebook un compte instagram mais ça
s'arrêtait là et nous on savait
pertinemment que d'en créer tout un tas
de compte au fil de notre vie d'ailleurs
une étude qui montre qu'on a en france
est en moyenne plus de 300 comptes sur
internet et donc nous on voulait
vraiment pro activement recherché
l'ensemble de ces fonds pour que la
famille n'est pas évidemment à devoir
rechercher et donc on a créé un
algorithme et des des programmes afin
d'aller chercher sur les réseaux sociaux
sur internet un maximum de données et en
fonction des comptes qu'on trouve ou pas
la famille peut soit décider de
conserver le compte de le supprimer de
le transformer en compte de
commémoration et ensuite on réalise
toutes les démarches à sa place dans
certains cas c'est un mail envoyé dans
d'autres cas c'est un coup de fil à
passer pour apple par exemple pour citer
microsoft il faut envoyer un courrier
recommandé en irlande pour se faire
appeler par un ingénieur de seattle ça
fait dix mois qu'on accompagne une
famille là dessus créé des grandes s'est
facilement supprimer c'est l'horreur et
on a mis en place une plateforme de
suivi pour qu'elle puisse dans un clin
d'oeil savoir où on en est dans toutes
nos démarches
il
[Musique]
j'ai connu cette société par
l'intermédiaire des pompes funèbres de
france qui nous ont proposé le service
quand on a fait les démarches pour la
cérémonie et j'ai trouvé ça plutôt très
intéressante est ce que moi je voulais
pas que les adresses mail ou autres
contacts sur le net de mon fils soit
éventuellement piraté et que
l'usurpation d'identité on s'est pas
posé de question pour nous les toutous
tôt supprimés
pour nous c'est pas notre métier voilà
l'informatique on a des connaissances
mais ont malgré tout on est quand même
limité c'est très technique il le fait
que quelqu'un se charge de tout effacer
de tout nettoyer pour moi j'étais
rassuré aussi voilà c'était c'était
vraiment important même si c'est
toujours dans un contexte douloureux
bien sûr et justement les familles elles
sont en deuil elles ont d'autres
préoccupations dont il ya beaucoup de
choses à gérer donc c'est vraiment un
gros poids qui se retire et c'est
vraiment une aide très précieuse
[Musique]
c'est un atout des djeun pour porter ce
projet parce que on connaît très très
bien le problème on est en tant que
jeune super utilisateur est hyper
connecté il ya beaucoup de gens qui nous
ont dit mais qu'est ce que vous faites
fi nalement enfin je vous êtes quatre
jeunes nous entreprenons dans la mort
c'est pas et nous ce qu'on aime
finalement c'est le côté mois déjà c'est
le côté paradoxal et pas très sexy et
quand on voit le ce qu'on apporte aux
familles et le soutien qu'on leur
apporte on est tout à fait content et
très heureux de les aider dans un tel
moment finalement les familles ont une
certaine forme aussi de d'empathie pour
nous qui alors qu'on sortait tout juste
d'études qu'ils décideront de se lancer
dans l'entrepreneuriat de créer un
service pas comme un difficile
et puis finalement il y avait on
totalement séparée de cette image de
peut-être des grandes pompes funèbres ou
des conseils funéraire qui font ça un
peu à la chaîne et qui qui ont tout à
fait cette notion de business
d'industrialisation alors que nous on
n'est pas du tout dans ce genre de
démarche on accompagne personnellement
chacune de nos familles alors au début
ça fait très bizarre
d'ailleurs on faisait tout pour ne pas
être en contact direct avec famille
parce que j'entends paraît que même moi
ça me faisait peur au début on voulait
un maximum garder une distance les
accompagner à la limite par mail mais on
a vu qu'ils avaient tout beaucoup de
questions et donc un moment on a dit que
si on voulait faire quelque chose de
qualité il fallait les contacter et je
me souviens encore ce premier appel
téléphonique qu'on avait faits où on
avait une voix toute tremblante et
finalement on était plus est n'est que
la personne elle même qui recevait son
coup de fil mais enfin on a continué
parce qu'on a vu que c'était nécessaire
et puis on a commencé évidemment à
professionnaliser le discours et puis
surtout aussi à savoir comment échanger
avec une personne endeuillée puisque
évidemment c'est c'est pas anodin
travailler dans le milieu funéraire oui
ça change
le rapport que tu as à la mort parce que
c'est quelque chose qu'on vit tous c'est
un événement qu'on va tous finir par
rencontrer malheureusement est temps
qu'on l'a pas rencontré dès que ça
arrive c'est vraiment le sort qui
s'acharne et c'est très difficile et
c'est ça permet de relativiser de dire
que ça arrive à tout le monde et ça
donne envie finalement de de profiter de
la vie à chaque instant qui profitait de
ses proches parce que ça montre à quel
point c'est précieux